and now for the moment you've been
waiting for let's hit this green run
button it will prompt us to choose a
device without a physical device we can
test the app using the emulator that
comes with Android SDK an Android
virtual device should have already been
created for you automatically when you
set up Android studio so you can go
ahead and click OK
while the emulator is booting up I want
to point out that if you ever want to
modify your emulated devices you can
click on this purple button and the
Android and open up the AVD manager to
manage your Android virtual devices it
lists out your existing devices and you
can always create another virtual device
you can select the category of device
and then a specific device then you
choose which platform version it should
be running on and this is the only one
that's available on this computer now so
a lollipop is good and we choose the
Google API is target because it will
include some Google services already
pre-installed on the emulator you can
choose next
there's a couple more options and
settings that you can modify for example
if you want an SD card or a camera and
then you can go ahead and click finish
and it will create a new AVD for you
when it loads up we see our sunshine app
with the words hello world keep in mind
that the emulator is not just a
simulator it's actually running the
Android virtual machine so you can test
and debug your app on different hardware
and software configurations you can
interact with the app on the emulator
using the screen or with the navigation
controls here you can also invoke other
apps do network calls play audio or
video and much more it also includes
debug capabilities including log output
and the ability to simulate app
interrupts or network latency you can
also hit home and browse around the
device to see other apps for example you
can check out API demos feel free to
play around with the emulator some more
if you open up Android device monitor
you can go into the emulator control tab
there you'll see different options for
simulating behavior on your AVD such as
for telephony and for location
now that the hello world app runs on the
emulator let's see what goes on behind
the scenes to make the app run